bonjour à toutes et à tous et puis bien
bienvenue pour ce nouveau webinar
consacrée aujourd'hui un gg pelote de et
à la grammaire des graphiques
donc on va aborder ce package qui est un
des package est essentielle pour pour la
réalisation de graphiques
en tout cas je suis en tout cas ravi de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau cycle de
deux sessions autour de autour des
graphiques donc nous avions eu la
semaine dernière une session foire aux
questions et donc géré préparé un
programme pour ce troisième cycle
donc aujourd'hui on va aborder un gg
pelote 2 et la grammaire des graphiques
on reviendra ensuite sur les plan
d'échantillonnage complexe et les
données pondérées notamment à travers le
package servait on continuera notre
exploration la manipulation de données
avec notamment le package taille d'hier
qui permet de restructurer ses données
de format long format large il les
remettre en forme
et puis nous aborderons l'analyse des
correspondances multiples et les anis
factorielle de manière générale et la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
ou ch ce qui nous amènera à une
prochaine session foire aux questions à
la fin du mois de mars donc surtout par
rapport à vos analyses personnelles
ce que vous faites de votre côté ce qui
émerge n'hésitez pas des cessions et
faqs où on est en discussions directes
sont celles qui
qui vont permettre de d'aborder plus
concrètement les problèmes que vous
rencontrez avec vos propres données on
continuera ensuite le programme a alors
l'ordre des sessions est pas encore très
très clair mais après ce prochain cycle
de toute façon nous reviendrons sur les
rapports automatisés avec la remarque
down on a fait jusqu'à présent des
rapports très simple avec la fonction
compas louis pauthe mais on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin
on abordera les données biographiques
avec l'analyse survie
et l'analyse de séquences et puis
j'essaierai de ré organiser des sessions
autour d'exemples de graphiques plus
avancés avec gégé pelote 2 de toute
façon on verra un les graphiques vont
revenir dans les différentes analyses
que l'on fait à un moment donné
peut-être une session sur un objet un
peu compliqué qui sont des trajectoires
de soins et puis en vous montrant
plusieurs manières d'aborder cet outil
là avec de l'analyse de survie de
l'analyse aux séquences mais différents
types de modèles on viendra aussi sur la
régression logistique multi nami a l'air
ordinale et puis sur d'autres types de
modèles les modèles de poissons
peut-être abordé mordelles des modèles
locke binôme you ou des modèles probitas
ou différentes manières voilà on
reviendra sur comment choisir le modèle
par rapport aux données que l'on a de
même que l'on abordera la question des
différents types de contraste dans les
modèles de régression qui sont les
contrats c'est la manière dont on va
avoir pour coder des variables qui sont
à qualitative catégorielles qualitative
catégorielles et de même peut-être qu'on
essaiera d'organiser une séance autour
de comment prendre en compte des
variables continue dans nos modèles avec
différents exemples puisqu'on peut les
côtés de manière linéaire simple ou de
manière polynomiale en mettant par
exemple une info mais la gela jocard et
puis voir même l'âge au cube plage
puissance 4 ou aborder des speed quoi
qu'il en soit on le programme va se
construire au fur et à mesure sachant
qu'une partie des ces enseignes sont
encore des chapitres écrits sur un
analyseur et donc ça va se faire aussi
un petit peu en fonction de mes
disponibilités pour le faire et ce qui
ne pourra pas être revus avant le mois
de juin
ce pourra être prolongée à la rentrée de
septembre
peut-être sur un format un petit peu
différent avec des sessions qui sont un
peu plus espacées quoi qu'il en soit je
vous propose d'aborder le sujet du jour
alors je vais vous mettre mon écran en
grand et donc aujourd'hui nous allons
revenir sur la grammaire des graphiques
avec
ggp lot 2 j'ai bien entendu et je
remercie celles et ceux qui ont répondu
à la petite enquête sur les webinaires
que vous souhaitiez avoir le plus
possible des exemples concrets
donc ce qu'on va faire déjà vous
retrouverez les éléments d'aujourd'hui
donc pour ceux qui ne s'en souviennent
pas le site qui va avec les webinaires
est accessible à cette adresse là sous
l'onglet séance vous voyez la liste des
différentes séances et avec à chaque
fois vous avez des ressources
supplémentaires si je vais sur la séance
d'aujourd'hui
vous trouverez des liens vers des
chapitres analyseur et donc notamment on
va commencer avec le chapitre
introduction à gg pelote 2 donc pour le
coup c'est un chapitre qui n'a pas été
écrit par mois mais qui a été écrit par
françois briatte puisque c est issu
d'une séance de cours qui l'avait fait à
des étudiants en économie
donc on aura des exemples un peu plus
économique aujourd'hui qu'ils vont nous
permettre de commencer à voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut jongler avec gégé
pelote 2
et puis vous avez aussi un renvoi vers
le chapitre graphique unis vivaient avec
jean claude decaux l'on abordera par la
suite et surtout je vous renvoie vers il
n'y a pas beaucoup d ouvrages dans aer
que j'ai vraiment utiliser au quotidien
à part peut-être celui ci qui est art
graphique secoue books par wilson sean
brosnan d'âge alors l'ouvragé en version
papier doit coûter une cinquantaine
d'euros il n'est pas forcément donné
mais il existe également en ligne de
manière totalement gratuite et c'est
vraiment une
une pépite lorsque l'on veut faire des
graphiques sous serre puisque vous avez
voilà si j'ai pas si vous voyez à gauche
vous avez le menu et vous avez un
paragraphe la grave donc vous avez type
anti ferrand types de graphiques
squatteurs pelote
donc on va retrouver plein d'éléments un
par un et puis surtout on n'a pas besoin
de tout lire d'un coup mais c'est
vraiment un bon endroit où aller
chercher par exemple je vais juste
changé un élément de la légende et ben
on va aller voir le chapitre consacré à
la légende donc en fait chacune de ses
entrées
c'est vraiment autour d'un concept et au
fur et à mesure et bien on peut
apprendre à utiliser il va vous redonner
les éléments qui sont là donc c'est
vraiment une ressource importante pour
les graphiques on peut faire extrêmement
on peut faire beaucoup beaucoup de
choses avec gégé pelote 2 aujourd'hui on
va vraiment voir les bases et puis au
fur et à mesure on verra comment est-ce
qu'on peut customiser tout ça il y
aurait en soi de quoi faire de
nombreuses séances urgent et pelote 2
alors pour démarrer la journée on va
ouvrir à air studio vous pouvez voir ici
je suis passé où air version 4.0 4 qui
est sorti tout récemment puisqu'elle
date du 15 février dont du début de
semaine
en tout cas je vous invite régulièrement
lorsqu'il ya une nouvelle version de
l'air d'une part à installer la nouvelle
version de m donc là je parle bien ter
et non de leur studio c'est bien de
logiciels complémentaires et surtout
pensé régulièrement allez dans l'onglet
package à cliquer sur aube d its pour
voir s'il ya des mises à jour de vos
package et du coup régulièrement à faire
ces différentes mises à jour qui permet
de régler un certain nombre de bugs au
fur et à mesure qu'ils sont identifiés
dans les dents les différents package
pour la session d'aujourd'hui qui est du
coup notre webinaire numéro huit s'est
bien on va faire un projet je voulais
dit c'est important de prendre
l'habitude d'organiser son travail en
différents projets alors sur des des
analyses de longue durée on aura un
projet auquel on va travailler pendant
plusieurs mois mais donc du coup je vais
aujourd'hui créer un nouveau projet pour
rappel c'est tout en haut à droite
je clique sur project je vais cliquez
sur new project pour créer un nouveau
projet et on va attendre que la fenêtre
s'ouvre
excusez moi mon ordinateur et un petit
peu long aujourd'hui entre le cast en
direct je vais choisir mieux directory
je vous rappelle version control c'est
pour dédé vraiment des usages plus
avancés avec guy tsbm donc si vous ne
connaissez pas ces outils-là oublier
choisissez tout simplement new directory
vous avez ensuite tout un tas de choses
plus compliquées qui quand on veut créer
des package ou des sites web
nous ce qu'on veut c'est simplement
créer un nouveau projet je vais
l'appeler webinaire 08
on veut le faire là par défaut de le
mettra dans mes documents mais je peux
cliquer sur bois aux uns pour choisir un
autre endroit pour mettre mon projet et
je clique sur cour et project l'aer
studio est en train de créer le
répertoire pour le projet sur lequel on
va travailler aujourd'hui
et puis il va réouvrir la console autour
du projet du jour alors je lis un même
temps le texte qui va avec
donc du coup aujourd'hui on va déjà
abordé un premier exemple qui est autour
d'une étude de cas est qui
qui est lié en fait il ya quelques
années il ya les chercheurs carmen
reinhart et kenneth rogoff qui publie un
article intitulé wife is not karimov
peps dans lequel il faisait la
démonstration qu'un niveau élevé de
dette publique nuisent à la croissance
économique et une plus exactement les
deux chercheurs ils défendent l idée que
lorsque la dette publique dépassait à
90% du produit intérieur brut
ce produit c'est cette croître autrement
dit lorsqu'on a une trop grosse dette
le produit intérieur brut n'augmente
plus dans un pays alors cette conclusion
qui est proche du discours portées par
des institutions politiques comme le
fonds monétaire international
elle a alimenté de nombreux débats des
parlementaires américains sont servis
pour exiger une diminution du budget
fédéral
et puis la commission européenne s'est
appuyée à l'époque sur cet argumentaire
pour exiger que des pays comme la grèce
durement frappée par la crise financière
globale de 2008 adoptent des plans
d'austérité drastiques
or il se trouve qu'en tentant de
reproduire des résultats de reinhart et
rogoff les chercheurs thomas enders
michael h et robert pauline et ont
trouvé de nombreuses erreurs ainsi
qu'une bête erreur de calcul dû à
l'utilisation pas tentent ils de
microsoft excel qui avait été utilisé
pour tout ça et donc du coup la
régulation de les erreurs donna lieu à
un débat très vif entre adversaires et
partisans des politiques économiques
d'austérité et qu'un débat qu'on
retrouve toujours aujourd'hui
alors moi je ne suis pas un spécialiste
ou l'économie là je vous lis
l'introduction qui a préparé françois
briatte dans sa note de court mais ça
nous donne un peu d éléments de contexte
pour savoir sur quelles données on va
travailler
donc du coup aujourd'hui on va
travailler sur les données de rallye
nature goff comptait légèrement corrigé
pour évaluer la cohérence de leurs
arguments sur le rapport entre
l'endettement et croissance économique
et pour ça on va commencer par récupérer
ces données au format csv
alors elles ont été fournies par un
chercheur américain qui s'appelle cosma
chat l'isi et jean vous les ai mises à
disposition sur le site
donc oui binaire dont je vous rappelle
quand vous êtes sur la page d'accueil du
site web in her vous cliquez sur séance
qui nous amène sur la lys et ses enjeux
et prend la séance d'aujourd'hui
et là vous avez un lien qui vous permet
de télécharger le fichier csv dont il
est question
je vais cliquez sur ce lien pour
télécharger les fichiers et la première
chose que je vais faire c'est enregistré
dans mon répertoire de travail donc en
l'occurrence je suis dans documents
webinaire f08 et donc je vais
enregistrer
du coup dans mon projet mon fichier de
données revenons maintenant à air studio
je vais écrire un script donc là je fais
un nouveau script donc ici c'est
d'apporter sur l'analyse de des ppte
point csv contre l'ess au petit ou
l'icône ici à sauvegarder j'ai tout de
suite créé mon fichier
donc je vais en créer un nouveau fichier
je vais l'appeler depth analysis point m
et puis première chose qu'on va faire
c'est de charger le talent diverses
puisque nous allons l'utiliser comme
toujours et ggp lot 2 fait partie du tag
divers sons qui sera automatiquement
chargés en mémoire et puis maintenant
j'ai chargé mais donnez donc on souvient
pour importer un fichier csv
on a recours à la fonction weezer qui
est fournie a du moins huit csv qui est
fournie par le package leader donc je
vous le fait de deux manières une
première manière rapide 1 je vais faire
des ppte cwid 6 sv et du coup il est
tout simplement ici de manière locale
donc là ça m'a apporté mon fichier si je
ne me souvenais plus la bonne syntaxe à
adopter je vous rappelle on peut aller
dans data imbot data cette femme texte 1
les fichiers csv ou comment
s'appelle-t-il value ce sont des
fichiers de type texte
et fameux texte avec leader là je peux
faire bronze pour aller chercher mon
fichier
d'accord et il ya automatiquement un ce
que fait widder il va essayer de repérer
c'est quoi le séparateur de décimales de
milliers il nous fait une première
proposition qui ici qui correspond
exactement à ce que ce dont on a besoin
et on voit que la commande c'est louis
ii csb sachez qu'on aurait été sur un
fichier en français on aurait peut-être
pu non pas la virgule coma mais le point
virgule semi colonnes comme séparateur
de valeur et pour configurer que notre
séparateur décimales aurait été une
virgule est pas un point il faut ni sur
locales comme figure est ici on peut
indiquer un éventuellement un des
ciments la marque qui serait différent
mais la même manière on peut vérifier
tous les éléments ce qui est à retenir
c'est si on regarde le fichier csv est
telle qu'il donc je vais faire view file
pour l'ouvrir dans la console pour voir
comment ce qui se présente en fait dans
la console
ce qu'on voit c'est que les données sont
bien séparées par des virgules on peut
toujours regarder elle a donné sous
chose de plus le plus construit alors si
je veux regarder maintenant voyez quand
j'ai importé j'ai eu un petit message
qui me dit missing colom names
feuillantine x1
donc si je regarde le fichier obtenu je
fais un view teps la première colonne
n'avait pas de nom de variables et donc
du qu'automatiquement on lui en
attribuer un puisque toutes les colonnes
doivent avoir un nom qui s'appelle ici
x1
alors pour vous représenter ces données
qui sont donc ces
elles contiennent pour un échantillon de
20 pays occidentaux et c'est dans la
colonne quang tri on voit qu'on a en
tout 1000 171 observation pour cinq
colonnes donc on a une ligne par pays et
par année dont pour chacun de ces 20
pays membres de la zone ocde on à la
croissance de leur produit intérieur
brut
donc bref qui correspond à la croissance
du pib et on a le ratio ici entre leur
dette publique et ce produit intérieur
brut
donc ça veut dire que en 1950
en australie le pib avait augmenté de 6
9%
c'est d'abord la croissance est déjà
donnée en pourcentage ici donc s'étaient
multipliés par cent et le ratio dette
sur pib était de 109 8 autrement dit la
dette était égal à 100 9 8% du pib
nous avons donc nous avons donc
plusieurs points d'observation dans le
temps par pays ce qu'on va commencer par
faire c'est déjà supprimé cette première
colonne qui ne va pas nous être utile
donc un petit peu de nettoyage teps et
pour retirer une variable si vous vous
en souvenez avec des plats hier c'est
tout simplement select - la variable que
je veux supprimer donc cx1
donc maintenant si je regarde des ppte
j'ai bien les mêmes observations
qu'avant j'ai juste cette variable ambre
pour avoir une petite idée du nombre
d'observations que l'on a par pays on
peut faire tout simplement un tableau de
fréquences pour rappel on peut faire un
alors plusieurs manières de le faire je
peux faire table d'eps ces conneries
lorsqu'il avoue le faire donc là j'ai un
tableau de fréquences tout simple si
j'ai quelque chose un peu plus au lit je
peux passer un par la fonction frais qui
est dans package questionnaire alors si
là je fais freq de telles conneries il
va me dire il ne trouve pas la fonction
feraient qu'un pour rappel soit je
charge le package cautionnaire en
mémoire soit éventuellement j'appelle la
fonction en précisant le nom du package
si je fais ceci ça me permet d'avoir
recours à la fonction feraient qu deux
questionnaires sans avoir besoin de
charger en amont le package prochaines
heures c'est intéressant qu'on trouve
une fonction juste de manière ponctuelle
une autre manière enfin de le faire
j'aurais pu partir de depth j'aurais
fait gouttes
by country et quand donc je prends les
fonctions de des planeurs
comme me permet de compter les lignes
comme gmic goodbye quand je suis à me le
fais par pays et donc je la j'obtiens
directement le nombre d'observations par
pays ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on a
à un nombre d'observations variable qui
va de 40 pour la grèce jusqu'à 64 pour
l'australie puisque pour certains pays
nous n'avons pas forcément des points
d'observation à toutes les dates
si je veux garder les années minimum et
maximum je peux aussi faire un saut
mairie de des ppte hier et qui me permet
de voir que on a des données qui vont de
1946 jusqu'à 2009
alors pour la suite ce qu'on aimerait
c'est bénéficier d'une variable qui
correspond à la décade parce que ça va
nous servir pour certains des graphiques
et donc du coup comment est ce que je
peux obtenir une variable décade
on va voir ça se fait tous assez
facilement pour rappel donc nous avons
la fonction hier qui contient du coup
l'année et qui est saisie sous forme de
nombres je vais faire une division
entière par dix donc la division entière
[Musique]
elle se fait avec pourcentage barres
obliques pourcentage est en fait on
divise par dix me retire le reste donc
j'obtiens du coup 2003 va donner 200
sites où ce résultat l'âge de leurs
multiplie par dix j'obtiens tout
simplement 1950-2000 1990 donc en fait
en faisant ma division tiers par 10 puis
en multipliant par dix je supprime en
fait la mention de l'année et donc
j'obtiens 1950 pour toutes les années de
la décade 1950
donc j'ai fait une seule variable des
ppte décade qui va est égal à tout ça et
comme on va l'utiliser un peu plus tard
non pas comme une vague continue mais
plutôt de manière catégorielles je vais
la transformer en facteur d'accord et
donc on va faire des petits décade égale
factor de dept les cadres alors petite
précision j'aurais pu écrire aussi tout
ça de manière un petit peu plus à la 10
place hier par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
ça c'est une syntaxe air un peu
classique donc pour vous réécrire le
même code
à la 10 place hier ça sort avec un
beauty look miu tate décade qui est égal
à factor de hyères divisions entières
par 10 x 10 donc tout ça va pouvoir me
remplacer si je leur exécute un en
appuyant sur je récuse tout depuis le
début j'ai tour exécuté et ici je
regardais pts délicate j'ai bien une
nouvelle variable décade qui est là et
qui du coup est un facteur avec les
niveaux 45 1950 1960 1970 80 90 et 2000
alors première chose qu'on va faire pour
visualiser nos données on veut voir à
quelles sont on va déjà regardé la
croissance du pib au cours du temps donc
on va faire un tout premier graphique ce
que l'on veut c'est réaliser un
graphique
je vais mettre les années un variable
continue puisque les années sont rentrés
sous forme d' entier dont je crois que
je vais refaire un look fort pour vous
je vais chercher aussi la balle tu que
vous l'ayez en mémoire si je fais un
look for the depth donc on a le pays
textuel donc ça sera pour être gérée de
manière catégorielles l'année qui est en
dbl c'est donc un nombre gonfle ratio
qui sont dénombrés des quatre qui est un
facteur
on a donc des cades et quand free qui
sont des barrières catégorielles et year
of erichot qui sont des variables
continue donc j'aimerais faire un 1er gr
fier qui va représenter l'ensemble de
mes données d'un sous forme d'un nuage
de points avec un x donc à l'horizontale
l'année et le niveau de croissance en
ordonnée on va voir déjà que quand on
veut faire des graphiques très simple on
peut utiliser la fonction qu club alors
la fonction couple est d'ailleurs vous
allez voir je vous la présenterai
aujourd'hui par la suite on verra
syntaxe plus complète de ggp lh2 que
j'utilise pas ce qui fait du coup
j'utilise rarement culotte mais qu
pelote qui veut dire coup de bluff
d'accord je fais équipe logic
qu'est ce que je veux en x et ben en x
j'aimerais représentés hier et
j'aimerais représentés on y est on va
indiquer data égale teps le fichier de
données
[Musique]
donc alors juste avant je vois une
petite question qui traîne qui est elle
pourquoi pourcentage par oblique
pourcentage est pas simplement la barre
oblique
je reviens sur ce petit point là qui
était de faire une la décale si je fais
3 / 2 j'obtiens un ennemi si je re
multiplie sa part 2
j'obtiens de 3,6 je vais faire une
division entière c'est à dire je veux
que le début je veux un
mais je veux pas les décimales c'est
pour ça que c'est ce qu'on appelle une
division entière que j'obtiens avec le
symbole % barres obliques pour son
et dans ce cas là j'ai que la partie
entière de la division et si je redis
multiplie par deux du coup j'obtiens que
depuis ce qu'on a perdu
là on utilise cette astuce pour faire
une décade c'est à dire si je prends
1980 7
je fais une division entière par dix et
que je re multiplie par dix j'obtiens
1980 donc en fait 1987 division en tire
par dix ça nous donne 198 x 10 on
obtient 1982 la même manière que 1984
aurait donné 1980 donc ça nous permet de
perdre dans cette astuce nous permet de
perdre une précision et donc de bien
créer une variable décade avec et la
même valeur pour toutes les années de la
même des caps c'est-à-dire de 1981 à
je reviens maintenant à montcuq l'hôte
donc vous avez ici qu plotin c'est pour
faire des graphiques assez rapide et on
indique la variable qu'on veut ma paie
en x la variable + l'on veut représenter
en y data galles d'eps et par défaut on
va avoir un graphique qui va être ici en
point ça essaye de s'adapter au type de
données que l'on a mis que l'on à
représenter l'intérêt que l'on a avec à
donc là chaque point représente un des
pays japon représente
on a un point par pays et par année on
voit l'ensemble des éléments pour y voir
un peu plus un peu mieux on aurait
intérêt à regarder les données et par
pays et pour ça on va pouvoir avoir
recours à la fonction facettes wap
première idée que l'on peut avoir avec
des graphiques j'ai piloté la notion de
facettes
on va faire des sous graphique selon une
variable donc supposons je reprenne mon
code et je vais rajouter alors le
symbole plus on va voir avec ggp
l'auteur en fait on est sur une logique
addictives c'est à dire qu'on fait
quelque chose
et puis dès qu'on veut faire une
modification c'est plus et on appelle
une autre fonction et je vais appeler
facettes wap et je vais indiquer une
variable
alors pour faire cette fois pour vale
indiqué sous forme d'une équation d'une
formule donc avec un until death et je
vais indiquer carrosserie et voyez on
vous enregistre cette petite
manipulation simple j'ai refais mon
graphique point par point
on la refait en faisant un saut
graphique pour chacun des pays et est ce
que fait face cette frappe c'est qu'il
essaye de trouver le nom de lignes et de
colonne adéquates pour que tout
s'affiche relativement facilement à
l'écran
[Musique]
petit élément de syntaxin pour pouvoir
mettre mes éléments de syntaxe sur
plusieurs lignes et que ce soit plus
facile à lire
vous aurez remarqué un jeu mais mon plus
à la fin de la ligne et je mets la suite
de ma commande sur la ligne d'après
puisque comme ma ligne se termine par un
opérateur
ici plus r c'est que la commande n'est
pas terminée qu'elle se poursuit sur la
ligne suivante si j'avais fait ceci
j'aurais eu un problème parce que qu on
aurait compris j'exécute cette commande
là et ensuite il éxécuté comment doit il
a indi mais le plus on peut pas
commencer une commande par un plus
maintenant que c'est vraiment important
de se souvenir que si on veut mettre une
commande pour plusieurs lignes il est
impératif de terminer par un opérateur
pour que air sache que la commande se
poursuit sur la ligne d'après alors si
on revient à notre graphique
[Musique]
ici on voit bien qu'il ya eu des
variations important de donc cette
croissance du pays d1 a changé au cours
du temps si vous prenez un peu comme
comme le comme l'autriche
il ya une grosse croissance en sortie de
guerre et puis ensuite elle a baissé
on veut aussi que dans certains pays
voyez ici l'espagne on a toute une
période pour lesquels on n'a pas de
données notamment entre 1960 et 1980
alors là nous avons des points
peut-être que ce que nous aurions voulu
représenter c'est non pas des points
mais des lignes dans gg pelote la
manière dont on représente les choses
des points des lignes des segpa on verra
qui en a plein d'autres on peut faire
des rectangles l'on peut faire
on peut faire des bars on peut faire des
histogrammes il ya énormément de
géométrie différentes mais tous ces
éléments là s'appelle les géométries et
voir quand on naît avec qq club on peut
indiquer une géométrie en rajoutant geum
égal et non la géométrie qui nous
intéresse
si je fais que pelote avec manger on
line voyez là je récupère et d'avoir des
points
je récupère du coup et demi à la place
ça des avantages et des inconvénients
un des inconvénients envoyés par les
pour l'espagne c'est du coup les potées
relier ici il ne vous voit pas qui si
elle venait qui est tellement content
autre élément c'est d'être certains que
nos données sont bien trier je
m'explique je reprends des ppte géo
trier de manière complètement aléatoire
alors il ya une astuce quand on veut
trier de manière aléatoire on peut avoir
accès à l'art sans paul frac donc sans
peu le frac
ça permet de prendre qu'une fraction
d'un de manière aléatoire il va nous
prendre certaines observations et pas
d'autres mais si je dis simple phrase ça
illégal 1 c'est à dire son pour son lit
là tout n'est prendre mais dans un ordre
aléatoire
si je regarde maintenant à quoi
ressemble t pts j'ai des points qui sont
pas dans le même ordre différent pays si
je refais mon graphique
on a de la chance et les arts trier dans
certains cas les données sont pas du
tout alors peut-être pas avec culotte
mais quand on est pilote doit faire le
tri mais dans d'autres cas de figure
vous avez des données qui sont plus du
tout trier et donc on va se retrouver
avec des points qui vont dans tous les
sens on va voir un point en 1960 qui va
relier un point de mieux qu on va
ensuite remettre un point en 1970 est
donc on quand on veut être sûr que de
pas avoir de problème c'est de penser à
bien trier n'a de fichiers dans tous les
cas ici par sécurité je vais trier mon
fichier par pays et par année c'est
toujours une sécurité
c'est toujours une sécurité pour la
suite alors on va voir on peut aussi
combiner plusieurs j'aimais géométrie
ensemble et par exemple je pourrais dire
que je veux des lignes et des points
dans ce cas là j'avais passé de
géométrie à cucq lot
[Musique]
et donc du coup il va d'abord me tracer
delhi puis va me tracer des points une
petite une précision l'ordre des
géométries que l'on met ici est
importante
1 il dessine d'abord les lignes puis
dessine les points dans certains cas ça
peut avoir une importance de savoir dans
quelle est dans quel ordre on veut que
les éléments soient soient soient
représentés autre élément aussi qui est
important c'est à cette étape là je ne
cherche pas à savoir si mon graphique
est le plus beau si je préférais pas du
fond gris si je veux changer d'autres
éléments faut savoir qu'on peut faire
des graphiques qui sont extrêmement
jolie très élégant mais la première la
première information qui est essentiel
c'est vraiment déjà de concevoir son
graphique et seulement dans un second
temps de commencer à réfléchir une fois
qu'on a fait un graphique qui efficace
comment le rendre plus lisible
donc à un moment donné pour le moment
essayé pas de changer la police
on peut faire mais ce qui est important
c'est d'arriver à bien concevoir le bon
graphique 1 et par la suite on va avoir
des choses un peu plus complexe alors
avant d'aller plus loin
là vous avez vu que pelotant ça permet
de faire un graphique très très vite
mais pour la suite vous ne verrez jamais
utiliser la fonction culotte parce que
j'ai pris l'habitude de toujours
utiliser la syntaxe de base d'eau gg
plock donc ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que un graphique vgp lot
il a posé les mains de base un jeu donné
le fait que l'on associe certaines
variables à ce qu'on va appeler des
esthétiques qui on va voir ses
différentes esthétiques et des
géométries si je reprends le graphique
qu'on a vu qu'on a là je vais reprendre
le
le premier graphique celui ci ont créé
un graphique avec gégé pelote auquel on
va passer un jeu de données qui
s'appelle ici d'eps puis on va associer
des variables à des esthétiques
donc l'idée d'une esthétique c'est que
c'est une grandeur graphique que l'on va
faire varier selon une variable là les
deux premières esthétique que l'on va
voir ses x et y
donc à rs c'est la fonction qui permet
d'associer une esthétique parce que et
c'est x écrit avec le st het is et en
anglais donc je vais dire que x est
associé à hier hier y est associée à
broc et enfin on va appeler une
géométrie raison graphique en point
c'est une la géométrie s'appelle paint
tout les jeunes et trident ggp lot
commence par les termes j'ai sommes donc
s'il fait jeunes danseurs vous voyez
toutes les géométries possible oui il y
en a beaucoup et non la géométrie de
base qui va nous servir ses jeunes hôtes
donc si je refais ceux ci ont refait
notre tout premier graphique de tout à
l'heure et je peux éventuellement
rajouter non facettes frappe country
[Musique]
pour retrouver ce que l'on avait fait
donc seule taxe de base d'un graphique
on appelle ggp lot on lui passe un jeu
de données puis on appelle ars pour
associer des variables à des esthétiques
puis on appelle une géométrie
ça c'est le minimum requis ces trois
éléments là et après on va avoir plein
d'éléments additionnel qui vont arriver
il faut savoir en fait qu'un graphique
peut sauf être sauvegardés dans un objet
donc si je fais ça je sauvegarde
le graphique que j'ai fait dans l'objet
paix parce que je pourrai ensuite rhmani
pull épais celle n'affichera pas si je
veux l'affiché il faut que je lance paix
dans la console il ya une syntaxe qui
existe à skis c'est là où c'est un peu
celle là où c'est un petit peu parfois
compliqué alors la question est
tellement il ya une question qui me
demande si le signe + marche bien à la
place des palais avec des potes oui
effectivement il se trouve que j'ai plus
hot de a été conçu un moment donné où le
pape n'était pas encore sorti et donc du
coup j'ai plutôt été construit sur cette
syntaxe additive j'ai un objet puis je
lui rajoute des choses en fait l'objet
le graphique c'est un
tel qu'il est tel que si on regardait sa
structure à notre objet p voyez c'est
tout un tas d'éléments assez compliquée
qui disent comment calculer le graphique
et à chaque fois qu'on rajoute quelque
chose on vient modifier certains de ses
éléments
donc du coup retenez effectivement que
pour les g mais la logique est là c'est
la même que ce pack ou nan chen de
partie en partie je pense que si ggp lot
il y avait une version 3 qui serait
réécrite
on aurait probablement à une syntaxe
avec du pape
retenez que c'est un t rex avec des plus
pour les pilotes mais la logique un peu
la même qu' avec le pacs est à dire que
en termes de philosophie en rajoute au
fur et à mesure avant de vous montrer
d'autres types d'esthétique et mieux
comprendre ce qu'ils jouent avec les
esthétiques
1 je veux juste vous présenter quelque
chose rapidement passé aux comptes doit
avoir des exemples sur internet vous
verrez deux choses possibles
là je fais ggp lot des ppte jeu parce
que des deux clubs qu un fichier de
données puis j'appelle as vous avez
aussi la possibilité de faire ggp lot
des ppte et d'appeler ars dans gg pelote
pour dire x eygalières y
[Musique]
égale groff plus l'homme paul tu sais de
syntaxe la celle ci dans gg pelote je
passe les données puis j'appelle un ace
à l'intérieur dû gérer belote
c'est la même chose que j'appelle ggp
lot sans préciser les esthétiques puis
gelé rajoute avec la fonction as ça peut
être un peu confus les deux sont
équivalentes sur un analyseur j'ai
adopté plus tôt cette cette écriture là
parce que je trouve ça plus simple donné
esthétique géométrie mais les deux sens
qui va lancer quand je vais chercher des
du code sur internet des exemples vous
verrez les deux donc ne soyez pas étonné
il ouvrira même sûr que sur des
graphiques bien plus compliqué on peut
définir d esthétique spécifique que pour
certaines géométrie et pas d'autres je
reviens sont fait qu'on peut mettre
plusieurs géométrie pour reproduire ce
qu'on avait juste avant où on a fait
d'abord line puis boys je peux appeler
mon germ'line ici donc là j'appelle ggp
lot
j'indique comment les variables
s'associer aux esthétiques puis
j'appelle jaume line puis j'appelle
j'aime pas eu depuis j'appelle facettes
frappe alors
une des questions qui possible on sait
comment on associer des variables à des
esthétiques
voilà cette fameuse question du s
supposons que je regarde les hommes
politiques donc c'est important il faut
toujours essayer de savoir les regards
des led un qui est intégré parce qu'elle
est elle est importante
si vous regardez gm paint dans l'aide
des géométries on vous indique toujours
les esthétiques qui sont comprises par
une géométrie car chaque géométrie
comprend certaine esthétique et pas
d'autres je me pose t elle comprend x et
y est elles sont indiquées en gras ça
veut dire que ce sont des géométries
obligatoire pour pouvoir construire le
graphique
alors c'est la couleur de vos points
shipp
c'est la forme des points je vous
montrerai quelques exemples un peu plus
tard size c'est la taille du point fils
c'est le remplissage des points parce
que certains certains symboles ils ont
un trek se plaint à ça peut être un rond
rempli c'est à dire vous avez une
couleur du très dur on est une couleur
de remplissage du rhône alpha c'est le
niveau de transparence voulons voir ce
paramètre color alors color ici envoyer
les cris à l'américaine c'est aux ailes
aux usa la britannique qu'on aurait dit
c'est aux ailes ou air ne sue alors vous
inquiétez pas ce qu'ils ont besoin d une
chose qui était bien fait dans gg pelote
c'est que vous avez systématiquement les
deux écritures possible si vous écrivez
color avec où son usage sera compris
dans les deux cas revenons à cette
notion d'esthétique
si je fais mon graphique
et que j'écris color et galloway
d'accord
[Musique]
j'indique que je souhaite un associé la
couleur rouge à mes points de clamer
points sont dessinés en rouge
ce que j'ai fait j'ai donné une valeur
fixe à l'esthétique color mais je
pourrais et sa répondre à une des
questions qui avait été demandé ce qu'on
peut avoir une coloration père pays
servent à associer la couleur des points
à une des variables dans ce cas là ce ne
sera pas je vais vous remettra un des
exemples les uns près des autres je vais
copier ce que je vais faire je vais
n'ont pas donné une couleur à
l'intérieur de major mitri de manière
fixe et je vais dire que je vais
associer une variable à cette esthétique
couleur donc par iab s'appelle country
et donc ce café ggp lot
d'accord c'est qu'il a associé voyez mes
points sont dessinés différemment ici
avec mon facettes
supposons je fasse la même chose mais
sans phase est un film graphique on m'a
retiré le job la halle pour le moment et
je vais retirer le facettes on obtient
également la même chose
simplement cette fois ci tous les points
sont superposés les uns sur les autres
peut-être que pour une question de
lecture je voudrais que mes points soit
légèrement transparent quand ils se
superposent et je voulais 10 et alpha le
niveau de transparence
si je mets points 5 ça veut dire que je
veux 50% de transparence oui donc là
vous avez ici le niveau transparent un
élément qui est important avec nos
variable avec gégé pelote c'est que j'ai
plein de la distinction que d'une
variable catégorielles qui est codé soit
sous forme de texte soit sous forme de
facteurs est une variable continu et qui
va être un entier ou une variable de
bord comme ici nous avons un grand
nombre de catégories on a une sorte de
gradient qui est fermée quand vous avez
peu de catégorie il va plutôt prendre
des couleurs qui s'opposent et on
reviendra un petit peu plus tard sur
comment choisir une bonne échelle de
couleurs je peux aussi lui donner une
variable continu si j'avais mis ici au
lieu de m si j'avais mis une variable
continu par exemple rations qui était
mon autre variable catégorielles là
comme c'est une variable continu et les
chaînes est complètement différente
c'est une échelle de gradient qui va du
foncier au clair puisque c'est une
variable continu que l'on a mis
vermette ici qu'une chose et je vais
vous montrer que je peux aussi faire
varier je veux associer par exemple la
taille des points à ratio qu'il variable
continu si je fais ça je fais variés du
cou
la taille de mes différents points dont
chloration est élevé alors si je zoome
est ce qu'on arrive à tout voir au
niveau de la légende voyez là j'ai la
légende pour la variable ratio est donc
contre ce ratio est grand j'ai des gros
points lorsque le ratio est plus petit
j'ai des petits points donc en fait
cette idée où on associe variable à
esthétique
c'est ce qui la permettent de concevoir
notre graphique j'aurais pu ce qui est
différent que de fixer une valeur
[Musique]
un point ici
si je reviens sur j'aurais pu utiliser
size dans l'appel de la géométrie mend
si j'avais en disant ça illégal 3 c'est
juste pour fixer la taille des points
sur mon graphique dans ce cas là je n'ai
pas associée je ne fais pas varié le
paramètre size en fonction d'une
variable je me fixe une valeur mais je
peux faire modifier cette valeur pouvoir
avoir des points de plus ou moins grand
suivant mes graphiques
alors revenons un peu plus sur l'analyse
économétrique qui nous intéresse la
joute fait plein de petits graphiques
pour comprendre la logique de ggp lot
la question qui est quand même posé par
la nos économies c'est y at il un lien
entre eux la croissance du pib et
l'ampleur de la dette
donc on va faire un premier graphique
donc je vais stockés dans un objet que
j'appelle paie donc jauger pelote dept
mes données puis j'appelle à la baisse
et cette fois ci ce que je vais
représenter ces y greffe donc en y je
vais mettre la croissance qu'on avait
jusque là sauf qu'on x je vais m watch
you ce que vous voyez c'est qu' il n'y a
pas besoin de mettre xy sa pommette y
égaler puis x égales en droit c'est à
nous de choisir dans quel ordre on veut
faire la définition vous avez votre
mieux qu'on ne met pas de guillemets non
plus on met la variable et on va bien
c'est bien comprend compris comme la
variable groff dans le contexte des ppte
on est sur une syntaxe en contexte comme
on a un peu dandy plat hier donc ça ça
nous fait un graphique de base
donc feront à partir de là si j'affiche
juste paix il se passe pas grand chose
parce que j'ai pas encore appelée de
géométrie je vais faire payer plus jeune
punk pour représenter des points et la
question qui peut se poser c'est est-ce
que cette relation parce que la question
c'est est-ce que la relation entre
croissance du pib et ratio pib /
croissance a changé au cours du temps
donc on va regarder les résultats des
quatre par décade donc ce que je peux
faire c'est faire un facettes wap
sur ma variables des cadres alors là
j'ai mon graphique des quatre par décade
et ce qu'a essayé de faire face cette
frappe ses devoirs en fonction de la
taille s qui le nous de deviner un nom
de l'ia nombre de colonnes on peut
contrôler ainsi on veut par exemple
uniquement sur deux colonnes
je dois avoir pas avoir ngolle qui
permet de dire je le veux sur deux
colonnes mois ce qui m'intéresserait
c'est de pouvoir mettre vraiment ça en
côte à côte et du coup on peut faire il
ya une autre fonction pour les facettes
qui est la phase 1 qui la fonction
facettes grid qui permet d'indiquer des
variables en colonne ou en ligne
et voyez le dit alors la syntaxe un peu
changé mais une syntaxe avec des tilles
de paravent mais la nouvelle syntaxe un
peu changé c'est une liste de variables
chrétienne lives
donc si je fais vase deux décades ce
qu'ils demandent c'est que des quatre
soit mis entre dans var's l'âge un
graphique les uns au-dessus des autres
parce que par défaut le premier
paramètre c'est au bronze donc la
variable sont les unes au dessus des
autres
moi j'aurais plutôt voulu avoir des
graphiques côte à côte ont plutôt faire
varier les comets décadent colonnes et
donc dans ce cas là je l'appliqué aux
paramètres qu'on ce qui permet du coup
d'avoir un ces différents graphiques les
uns après les autres
on va voir mon nom c'est pour améliorer
la lecture de ce graphique là on
aimerait changer l'échelle 1d x qui est
ici pour avoir quelque chose qui soit
plus facile à lire ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la manière dont donc on peut
contrôler finement la manière dont une
variable est associé à une esthétique et
ça passe par les fonctions dites
d'échelle on score en anglais donc là je
vais modifier la manière dont on va
organiser l'échelle de la l'esthétique x
j'appelle donc ce qu'est un
ensuite il ya le nom l'esthétique et
puis il ya différents types d'échelle
qui sont possibles par exemple les
charles dickens x loeb 10 permet de dire
que l'on souhaite avoir une échelle
logarithmique plutôt que d'avoir une
échelle numérique classique
là en l'occurrence on va juste contrôler
l'échelle de ballons x est une variable
continue donc on va appeler sky x
continuous parmi les options on a break
ce box me permet de dire où je veux
avoir les points sur mon axe donc par
exemple moi je vais avoir des brax à 0
sont et de son
vous voyez là j'ai contrôlé et j'ai
changé ici les petites étiquettes en bas
indiquant précisément au moins je
voulais avoir mes coupures à l'écran si
je veut sauvegarder tous ces changements
là je peut sauvegarder tout ça dans paie
donc là j'ai défini paix une première
fois et je vais sauvegarder paix avec
ces modifications
abordons maintenant la question des
couleurs parce que je sens bien que on a
envie de voir des choses un petit peu un
petit peu plus fine
si vous vous souvenez dans dans
l'introduction on nous avait dit qu'une
des grandes questions s'étaient
notamment
il y avait l'idée selon les auteurs que
la croissance n'augmenter plus donc goff
serait forcément ne serait plus positif
lorsque la dette incluse ratio dette sur
pib dépasse les 90% donc rajoutons
associons donc ce qu'on veut sérieuse et
colorisé les points en fonction de la
valeur de ratio ratio on l'a vu un c
même s'il est représenté en bas un ratio
c'est c'est une variable continu là on
va faire directement un calcul je vais
mettre ratio inférieur à 90 donc quand
je fais un appel à rs je peux faire un
calcul directement j'aurais pu mettre
ratio carré je ne peux directement m un
calcul sur une variable est énorme et un
ratio inférieur 90g obtenir choo ou fall
sont fonction de la valeur de ratios si
je fais ce graphique là j'obtiens de
valeur chew files donc trop ça veut dire
que notre action est bien inférieur à 90
et fall comme indice
donc on a rajouté un paramètre
esthétique qui a été pris en compte
la question maintenant c'est peut-on
changer les couleurs et là ça nous
renvoie à comment est-ce qu'on définit
des couleurs dont m alors je vous fais
une petite aparté un sur les couleurs
déjà les couleurs dans l'air on peut
définir de deux manières soit on peut
leur donner
on peut les définir par leur nom
d'accord vous avez tous leurs j'avais
utilisé oued et vous avez sur internet
une liste de toutes les couleurs qui
sont comprises par r lorsqu'on donne
leur nom et vous en avez beaucoup ce qui
est à retenir c'est qu'on a quasiment
systématiquement à toutes les couleurs
de base doit être blanc orange queen à
vous avez aussi des versions dac orange
ou light orange donc vous avez un grand
nombre de noms de couleurs et alors on
peut pas toucher apprendre par coeur
mais c'est une première manière de
pouvoir appeler les couleurs dont m
l'autre manière de représenter les
couleurs de hertz à partir du code
hexadécimal alors pour rappel les
couleurs en informatique sont codés
selon la grille dit rvb wise un rouge
vert bleu ou rgb un onglet wide glide
green blue et chaque couleur a une
valeur entre 0 et 255 donc dans word par
exemple pourrait voir qu'une couleur
rouge a thread 154,00 non 2 154 00 ses
254 pour rouge zéro envers les hérons
blancs ses couleurs là une valeur entre
0 et 254 ça peut représenter avec deux
caractères en hexadécimal l'exode et si
mal c'est quand on représente des
valeurs av
avec une base 16 c'est à dire on a les
chiffres 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 puis les
chiffres a b c d e f
donc si je fais réd
[Musique]
la couleur rouge
d'accord c'est que je dise ces
représentations décimales ses 255 000 et
la valeur hexadécimal cff 00 00 alors
chaque couleur du coup peut être
présentés un par un code hexadécimal qui
se présente du coup sous une suite de
six chiffres les chiffres pouvant être 0
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 a b c d e f
précédé d'un diez et donc du conte pour
retenir cette valeur là maintenant ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point
c'est comment choisir les bonnes
couleurs pour représenter une grandeur
quand on a une variable qui continue on
a plutôt intérêt à représenter les
couleurs selon un gradient quand on a
des variables catégorielles on va cissé
ordonné on peut avoir recours un
gradient si c'est pas ordonner on va
chercher à voir des couleurs qui
s'opposent les unes par rapport aux
autres
alors est ce qu'on prend du bleu du
rouge avec du verre qu'est-ce qui va se
marier avec quoi c'est une question qui
peut être un peu compliqué et l'enjeu
c'est pas forcément de partir sur ce
qu'on trouve jolie ou pas jolis seins
mais c'est peut-être de partir sur des
travaux qui ont pu être faits alors
parmi les plus connus les plus connus
vous avez les travaux qui ont été faites
pas brève heures c'est pour ça qu'on
parle de collorgues rêveur il ya un site
web dédié qui sont des travaux qui ont
été réalisés par cynthia brévart marc
robert enke pennsylvania state
university qui ont cherché les palettes
de couleurs qui marchait bien pour des
cartes mais qui du coup marche plutôt
bien aussi pour faire des graphiques
vous avez ici le site coloré woerth you
dot org juste taper colobes rêveur sur
internet vous le trouvez facilement qui
vous présente les différentes
les différentes palettes de couleurs
première chose c'est d'indiquer le
nombre de classes que vous avez dans
votre palette donc le nombre de couleurs
différentes dont on a besoin
vous allez ici des palettes de couleurs
dit séquentiel donc pour une variable
continu ou pour une variable ordonnée
vous avez ce qu'on appelle les single
you
donc c'est à dire une seule teinte un là
uniquement du vert uniquement du bleu
vous avez des multi ue là c'est quelque
chose qui va du jaune vert le rouge
du moins orange vert rouge et là on est
yellow orange brawn
donc vous avez plusieurs teintes de
couleur on vous avez ici les codes
hexadécimaux de ces différentes couleurs
sur tout ce qu'ils ont regardez et vous
avez si l'information se classe par
exemple pour 5 modalités elle est
colorblind friendly ça nous dit du coup
que les personnes qui ont des problèmes
de vue il a distingué les couleurs donc
ils sont daltonienne comme on dit en
français là on a une palette de couleurs
qui pourra être vu correctement par des
personnes daltonienne toisième
informations c'est qu'elle est peut-être
pas photocopier friendly c'est à dire
que si jamais j'ai imprimé en noir et
blanc je photocopier une version du
document a dit qu on voit bien les
différences elle n'est pas considérée
comme lcd friendly c'est à dire comme ça
s'adaptant bien aux écrans et elle est
probablement pas porsche forcément très
adaptée pour une impression alors que si
je prends est-ce que j'ai des pointes
friendly là vous avez des palettes de
couleurs qui s'imprime ont plutôt bien
c'est à dire qu'il y aura encore à cette
contraste au monde l'impression si
jamais vous avez catégorielles vous avez
plutôt intérêt à prendre des palettes de
couleurs dit qualitatif c'est à dire en
charge et couleurs qui vont s'opposer
les unes aux autres et là on a
différents palette de couleurs
donc la nouvelle dans cas où on a eu
deux modalités voyez que chaque palette
à un petit nom ici 7 3 sets à 1 et il
est possible d'appeler une palette de
couleurs avec
alors avec gégé pelote dans gg pelote
donc revenons ici sur mon graphique 1
voulez vous le voyez il est là je veux
modifiée du coup les couleurs qu'on va
utiliser pour représenter le graphique
pour ça j'ai donc besoin d'une fonction
d'échelle donc ce cas là ce que je veut
modifier ses l'échelle de couleurs donc
c'est color et on va voir du coup
plusieurs on à la méthode manuelle
c'est moi qui vais donner directement
les couleurs je veux donc je vais faire
value et là par exemple j'ai dire il ya
l'eau nous donc quand je fais ça c'est
moi qui indique manuellement le nom des
couleurs qui m'intéresse j'aurais pu
mettre aussi un code couleur par exemple
rouge willis tff 00 00 donc si j'ai un
cône hexadécimal je peux indiquer diez
suivi du code hexadécimal pour indiquer
la couleur je veux donc là nous avons
mon graphique et j'indiquais rouge et
bleu autre possibilité s'est passé par
les couleurs bref heures donc ce que
color rêveur qui me permet d'appliquer
on
breva sur une échelle de couleur en
l'occurrence si je reviens ici et que je
veux du coup cette palette là qui
s'appelle pastel 1
je retiens le nom pastel 1 et ici je
vais indiqué pal est égale le nom de la
passe de la palette de coloris vert
alors pastel un loyer c'était un peu
léger 1
si je reprends la palette 7 1 qui était
je crois plus contrastée on obtient ici
une palette de couleurs un petit peu
plus costaud enfin dans les autres
palettes de couleurs il y en a une autre
que je vous serais vous présentez qui
issu des travaux de porto alors on va
chercher ça sur internet
pour sal colle aux pôles tels que je
revérifie et c1 c'est un scientifique en
physique atomique
et qui a travaillé pareil sur des
palettes de couleurs
et c'est palette de couleurs ayant fait
il il parle de travaux mathématiquement
de choses qui - nogent j'en suis pas
expert mais donc du coup il ya un
travail derrière de chercher des
contrats centre couleurs qui vont passer
pour un maximum de visions différentes
et donc ils proposent aussi des palettes
de couleurs ça c'est sa palette de base
qui s'appelle bright avec blue cyan
greenyellow reds alors les noms dans air
seront pas interpréter au sens de pôle
toile parce que vous avez ici les codes
hexadécimaux et donc ça ce sont
différentes palettes de couleurs qui
proposant différents schémas et qu'on
l'avantagent à ce sont des palettes
qu'ils sont efficaces pour les personnes
qui sont color blind qui pour les
personnes qui sont daltonienne qui ont
des contrats saas est important pour
convoler différence lorsqu'on les
imprime à ou contournée on les sort et a
donc là vous pouvez vous avez sur son
site toutes les explications du choix
des couleurs et des et le cadre
théorique ya derrière
et puis il a également fait des palettes
pour des départs divers jing donc ça
c'est quand on représentants du froid et
du chaud en passant par du zéro d'écart
de température et des palettes qui sont
séquentiel ça fait partie des autres
palettes de couleurs intéressante parce
que elle marche dans beaucoup beaucoup
de contexte il se trouve que les
palettes de couleurs de porto ont été
implémentés pour gégé pelote 2 elles
sont pas de base en gp2 mais elles sont
disponibles dans un package qui
s'appelle khroma donc si j'avais chargé
chrome axa qui s'appelle khr au m a donc
wistron qu'elle est déjà installé sur
mon pc
on peut alors refaire notre graphique
peut appeler ce qui re
color et la bright ce qui est la palette
de base de paul temps et on obtient ce
résultat là vous avez aussi un toutes
les autres donc si on veut plus
d'information on va sur le site de du
package chrome a découvert les
informations sur un package le plus
simple est de rechercher dans google
cran qui est là où sont stockés tous les
package cro bat en faisant ça j'arrive
sur la page de présentation du package
est souvent on a une url qui nous
renvoie vers le site officiel d'un
package donc là j'arrive ça va parler
d'aller sur le site du package khroma où
je retrouverai aussi plus d'informations
et sur les différentes palettes qui sont
complémentaires donc on retrouve un peu
les humains type de choses là ce que
vous avez non c'était la palette bright
un qu'on avait vu c'est comment est-ce
qu'elle va être vu par quelqu'un qui est
atteint de dos terrano pis comme ans
avait dû par quelqu'un qui atteint 2 pro
thanato pi et comment ça va être vu par
quelqu'un qui atteint de tri thanato pia
ou d'acrobates obtient donc voilà on
arrive sur des choses à noter un petit
peu plus compliqué mais ce qui va ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que voyez à ses
contrastes pour ses différents types de
situation donc quand on n'a pas le temps
de réfléchir à quelles palette de
couleurs parce qu'après les couleurs
peuvent aussi avoir un sens sociologique
ou autre retenez collab rêveur et la
palette de paul qui sont vraiment des
bons choix
ce sont des palettes qui marche bien
dans la plupart des cas on a des rendus
qui sont plutôt propre et qui sont qui
sont efficaces
alors autre élément
je vais revenir sur ce sur cette version
là donc avec la palette
sauf que ce que j'aimerais aussi c'est
là dans mon graphique et envoyé rouge et
bleu sont appelés farce est chaude
puisque ce que j'ai passé ces ratios
inférieurs à 90 d'un corps et donc ratio
inférieur à 90 ça me renvoie tout
simplement des valeurs qui sont farcis
tout et j'aimerais remplacer par des des
choses qui font un peu plus de sens ce
que je peux faire je peux personnaliser
les étiquettes pour les couleurs et dans
dance quelques rôles or je vais rajouter
label ce et je vais passer les
étiquettes que je veux donc si je fais
un ratio supérieur à 80 dans l'ordre
[Musique]
traces you will le premier qui
représentait un ciel rouge qu'il ratio
supérieur à 90 et l'autre qu'il ratio
inférieur à 90 et en faisant ça je
personnalise ça me permet de remplacer
les étiquettes cas dans la légende et ça
c'est intéressant parce que ici j'ai
fait mon calcul à la volée j'aurais pu
faire aussi un calcul est une variable
en amont en faire un reconnaît le
variable avec les bonne étiquette et
j'aurais passé un facteur alors
sauvegardons tout ça dans p
[Musique]
et maintenant je vais rajouter une
petite géométrie qui va être
particulièrement intéressante dans le
cas d'un nuage points qui s'appelle
geoff alors faisons pas plus j'aime ce
mot
[Musique]
qu'est ce que fait j'aime ce mot pour
bien comprendre
j'aime mousse ça ça me sèye je sais pas
si vous voyez bien je vais aux mille
graphique
j'aime smooth essaye l'accord de trouver
une courbe qui va suivre les points qui
va et donc il essaie de me représenter
la relation qui entrent mais entre mes
différents points j'annonce m'offre un
va être calculée ici pour chacun des
sous-groupes donc sa calculé séparément
pour ratio supérieur à 90 pour ratio
inférieur à 90 et sert au calcul et du
coup ici séparément pour chacune de mes
décade par défaut la technique utilisée
par jamie moss la technique laisse donc
simonet plus d'informations vous hésitez
pas à aller du coeur tu es james mousse
ou dans l'aide on vous présente en fait
les différentes méthodes qui sont
possibles et notamment sur la méthode
l'ouest qui essaye de trouver en fait
une courbe
qu'ils essayent de trouver une courbe
qui qui rejoint le plus en revient son
graphique qui essaye de trouver une
compagnie nominal qui va le mieux éviter
les données ce que j'aurais pu faire
et puis voyez au tournant en grisé ça
nous a rajouté un intervalle de
confiance
james moss on a plusieurs méthodes
possibles et si ce que je voudrais c'est
simplement les droite de régression
linéaire remplacer méthode par méthode
égal elle aime et voyez ça va me
rajouter les droite de régression
linéaire dans différents endroits
alors comme les couleurs sont couleur
sur couleur ça devient un petit peu
difficile à voir donc si je mets color
égale blacks en faisant ça loyers et un
petit changement qui s'opère une
esthétique alors je vais fixer une
valeur et donc du coup j'en sniffe 9 a
pu prendre en compte l' aesthetic color
qu'on avait en amont
donc du coup il cale toulon seule droite
pour l'ensemble des points dans chacune
des facettes
on représente du coup là la droite de
régression ici donc vous voyez quand je
fixe une esthétique dans un appel une
géométrie
ça va prendre ça ça remplace la
définition globale des esthétiques on a
fait au début avec ars enfin si je
venais géographique est pas indiqué les
intervalles de confiance au taux de main
droite de régression je vais rajouter s
se régale face
[Musique]
et donc là on voit du coup les faits un
peu globale et puis enfin ce qui serait
intéressant c'est que je ne sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais le un des
éléments premier qu'on nous avait dit
c'était que selon l'argument le il n'y a
plus de croissance lorsque il n'y a plus
de croissance lorsque la dette
minc le ratio dépasse 90 donc on
s'attendrait du coup que pour les points
qui sont situés à droite 1 qui dépassent
le haut ratio est supérieur à 90 ces
points-là soit tout simplement en
dessous de zéro puisque on s'attend à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de croissance
là ce qu'on voit actuellement c'est que
la croissance semble baisser la
croissance semble bien il ya une
tendance en tout cas ce que la
croissance baisse lorsque le ratio
dette sur pib augmente mais pas
forcément de manière systématique
une autre manière de regarder ça serait
de voir est-ce que j'ai des points qui
sont situées sous zéro donc plutôt que
de rajouter la droite linéaire j'aurais
juste afficher une droite horizontale
pour la valeur y gagnent 0 et ça je peux
le faire avec jets sommes donc là
j'aurai une droite horizontale donc ch
klein comme je me souviens plus des
paramètres dachnak je vais appeler geum
h line ici donc c'est pour faire une
droite h lun des lignes horizontales v
line une ligne verticale et hart lane a
besoin d'un paramètre qui va être y
intercepte on sait où est ce que ça
coupe mon graphique sur l' axe d y donc
gmh line y intercepte égal zéro le
permet de rajouter cette île est très
clairement puisque on s'attendrait à ce
que si jamais l affirmation était vrai
que quand on dépasse 90% du pays que le
ratio dette sur pib n'est pas 90 % la
croissance négative
on devrait pas avoir de point qu'ils
sont au dessus
enfin un autre petit élément je vous
présente ici c'est que donc on a
commencé à voir qu'il nous fallait des
données d esthétique des appels à des
géométries ce cas ça nous permet de
changer la manière dont une géométrie et
associés dont une variable est rattaché
à une géométrie et puis on va avoir
quelques éléments de personnalisation
additionnel d'une part on peut mettre un
titre
et ça ça se fait avec gégé title donc
ainsi jeu mais gégé title s'est donnée
reinhart et rogoff
corrigés donc là ça me permet de
rajouter un titre à mon graphique
il est aussi possible de mettre un sous
titre donc seul en parlant ce n'est
qu'en 1946 2009 vous avez la fonction
labs à la fonction labs
alors vous avez x l'ap pardon pour
l'accès x donc là c'est par exemple
ratio dette sur pib
et puis on va appeler y là pour l'ocde y
qui va être du coup taux de croissance
du pib
[Musique]
la besoin qui est plus générique 1 qui
permet aussi de configurer x et y permet
aussi de changer l'étiquette de toutes
les esthétiques donc là par exemple sur
color je peux changer l'étiquette que je
vais mettre dans ma légende donc là ça
va être ratio dette sur pib par exemple
vous voyez ça a changé
cette partie là du graphique donc retenu
on a toute une série de fonctions qui
permettent de changer les étiquettes du
graphique
et puis enfin on va avoir plein de
choses pour changer le thème général du
graphique
alors pour aller vite on a quelques
thèmes prédéfinis par exemple thème par
défaut de ggp lot s'appelle thème grèce
et pour ça vous voyez souvent ce fond
gris sur les graphiques ggp lot mais
vous en avez quelques en plus par
exemple thème black and white ce qui
permet d'avoir des jets
ou tu aimes light qui est aussi un thème
plus léger et puis enfin une fonction
générique thème alors ten je vais vous
montrer l'aide de thèmes ça permet de
changer à peu près tout mais pour
comprendre c'est qu'il ya énormément
d'éléments qui sont possiblement
modifiable vous avez ici la ligne
complète des éléments modifiable va par
la fonction thème
donc il y en a énormément et quand on
veut commencer à modifier ces éléments
de thèmes c'est qu'on veut faire des
choses très jolie une très très propre
on le verra sur ces exemples de
graphiques avancées mais au début vous
en souciez pas trop parce que sinon on
s'en sort pas par contre un qui peut
être intéressant c'est legends position
parce que celui-ci vous servira beaucoup
et donc en fait c'est vous pouvez vous
mettre les mots top bottom right left
donc par exemple si je fais les djeunes
position' left ça va vous mettre la
légende sur la gauche ou si je mets top
ça va me la mettre
oh d'ailleurs vous voyez que
automatiquement il nous à gg pelote
s'est adapté pour les mettre les
étiquettes les unes à côté des autres
plutôt que les unes au dessus des autres
il ya les adaptations qui se font alors
juste quelques instants pour voir les
une partie des questions vous avez fait
la numérotation des titres et automatisé
ou est ce qu'il faut le faire
manuellement
pour le moment vous faites vous-même
manuellement les titres de manière
générale retenez aussi que quand vous
préparez alors vous avez deux étapes 1
une première étape où vous explorez vous
explorez vos données n'essayez pas de
passer du temps à faire des graphiques
qui sont particulièrement beau passer du
temps à trouver quel est le programme
fiq pour représenter vos données parce
qu'on pouvait voir graphique est très
beau c'est juste que c'est pas le bon
graphique pour représenter les choses
dont vous avez vraiment toujours une
première étape qui est pensé à concevoir
quelle est la bonne manière de
représenter mes données parce qu'il ya
des représentations graphiques qui sont
adapté ou pas adapté à ce coup les faire
par exemple ne fait pas de graphiquement
camembert on pourra en discuter prénoms
des heures mais voilà il ya le choix de
concevoir le bon graphique
deuxièmement une fois vous n'avez cette
étape là vous aurez vous avez avancé
dans votre analyse vous allez préparer
les graphiques définitif pour votre pour
votre pour votre
[Musique]
pour un article ou pour un chapitre de
thèses souvent en fait vous aurez plutôt
intérêt à mettre le titre et le numéro
de graphiques pas dans le fichier image
mais dans le document word proprement
dit donc souvent vous aurez pas les
numéroter en direct mais en tout cas on
n'a pas de numérotation ici automatique
de disponible alors ensuite il y à force
et chaussons toujours affichée alors
fall cette fois ils ne sont plus
affichées si vous regardez le graphique
que j'ai fait ici
ils ont été remplacés par ratio
supérieur à 90 et ratio inférieur à 90
en fait on a modifié les étiquettes pour
color et donc ça ça s'est fait avec la
belle option label sedan scale color
donc si vous nous avons passé par vraie
ou fausse à voudront passer ce qui est
certain c'est que techniquement
l'idée show effaceront toujours écrire
en anglais en tant qu'objet est ce qu'on
peut changer ce sont des étiquettes
pourquoi pas le camembert
alors je suis remonté contre les
camemberts vous l'aurez compris je vous
dirais que à chaque fois que j'ai vu un
camembert dans un article que j'ai dû
retrouver c'était rarement un bon
article
il ya plusieurs éléments sûrs
sans avoir le temps d'aller trou dans le
détail il ya je vais vous montrer comme
un site intéressant qui s'appelle m graf
galerie donc le site air grave galerie
est retirée point graff points galerie
est un site qui vous présente plainte
graphique possible sous there je veux
faire un graphique ion est map
je prends la catégorie et vous aurez
autorisez vous aurez différents types de
graphiques qui vous aurez à chaque fois
en général du code qui correspond à ce
graphique là
et vous aurez du code r une partie sont
faits avec gégé pelote dont sont faits
dans d'autres contextes
en tout cas vous avez plein
d'inspiration pour plein de types de
graphiques différents et j'aimerais bien
ne pas voir les cookies qui pour
demander à chaque fois maintenant dans
ces catégories là il ya plein de
graphiques conflit des plus simple au
plus compliqué comme les stream shard
des cordes diagramme ou des drames de
sang qui il ya une catégorie tout en bas
on général knowledge sur ggp lot 2 vous
aurez des informations de base sont
jugées plutôt épique avait alors je suis
désolé c'est en anglais mais si vous
venez sur caveat en fait ça vous renvoie
sur un autre page de dates à tous vise
forme d'atteinte aux visualisation et là
vous avez une liste de choses à ne pas
faire
donc ça je vous invite vraiment à les
lire
c'est vrai faut bien sûr la liseuse à ne
pas faire c'est c'est un bon indicateur
et vous avez notamment paille charte
alors oui
alors on dit il faut pas faire de
graphiques en 3d et paris sont trompeurs
c'est vrai les graphiques en 3d sont
trompeurs maintenant je vous invite tous
à regarder rapidement ces trois
graphiques et à me dire si vous voyez la
différence entre ces trois graphiques
je vous donne une dizaine de secondes
et je vais vous montrer maintenant les
mêmes trois graphiques sous forme de
barres ce qu'on voit c'est que dans le
premier on a quelque chose qui
croissance stable dans le deuxième et
qui décroît dans le troisième ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que l'oeil humain est
bon a comparé des longueurs mais très
mauvais quand il s'agit de comparer des
angles donc un graphique en camembert en
soi est rarement une bonne
représentation
parce que du coup le arrive pas vraiment
à avoir que a du mal à voir comment les
choses évoluent et c'est pas forcément
la meilleure des représentations
maintenant un deuxième élément
un deuxième élément à retenir c'est quel
est le contexte du graphique si c'est un
art graphique qui a pour vocation
d'aller dans un article scientifique ou
dans une ou dans un papier je ne sais
pas combien j'ai vu d'articles
scientifiques y arriver avec un
graphique en camembert pour nous montrer
la répartition par sexe le disais voilà
dans l'échantillon il a 47 % de femmes
j'ai pas besoin des trafiquants
camembert pour savoir qu'à 47 % de
femmes
c'est un chiffre c'est largement
suffisant
mettez le mois dans le texte quand vous
écrivez un article scientifique où vous
écrivez un chapitre de thèse à un moment
donné la représentation graphique elle
est là quand elle permet de représenter
des choses qui ne serait pas lisible
avec un seul tableau j'ai envie de dire
une règle de base
il ya toujours des exceptions mais une
bonne règle de base c'est est ce qu'il
ya au moins douze nombre différent qui
définissent mon graphique là si je
prenais ce graphique là tout seul j'ai
pas douze noms différents
par contre si on rajoutait des
intervalles de confiance mais là tout
d'un coup on commence à en savoir plus
donc souvent un graphique là où une
figure est intéressant dans un chapitre
de thèse
dans un article scientifique c'est quand
la formation qu'on représente
ce ne serait pas aussi lisible que dans
un tableau lorsque le tableau est plus
facile à lire
il vaut mieux faire un tableau c'est un
petit peu différent lorsque lorsque l'on
va faire une communication
quand on est dans un powerpoint quand on
est en train de présenter des résultats
un public plus large
effectivement on peut avoir besoin de
quelque chose de plus visible mais si
vous voulez me représenter qui à 53%
fait plutôt éventuellement un donut ce
qu'on appellera donne aux sharks qui va
être dans ce type de représentation
graphique si vous prenez ce graphique là
il va peut-être être plus représentatif
que de faire un camembert
c'est tout bête on en a fait un donut et
puis là en plus on nous rajoute des
informations sur le côté qui vont faire
que ça soit plus lisible mais peut-être
que et ce serait à vérifier ça serait
peut-être plus pertinent et plus visible
de faire un graphique en barres avec
litanie 30% république tchèque 18 % en
irlande 12% donc souvent en fait une
autre présentation graphique serait même
plus pertinente
il y a d'autres cas de figure ça ce type
de représentation c'est intéressant
dans une communication parce qu'on a
quelque chose de très visuel
alors que ou ceux ci c'est à dire
représenter juste un pourcentage ou
celui ci représentait un pourcentage
avec une barque et plus ou moins
remplies c'est très visuel ça fait tout
un totalement sens de représenter cela
radan
dans sur un powerpoint mais il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à elle-même dans un article
scientifique ou un nombre de figures est
limitée par contre vous voyez là la
formation elle est répétée ces 80% 62%
77% qui est tout de suite visible et le
cercle autour n'est qu'un élément qui
vient illustrer ce qu'on est en train de
dire pareil sur ce type là donc ce type
de graphique là ça ça peut avoir du sens
de le représenter dans une communication
qu'on va avoir
par contre de faire un camembert pour me
dire qu'il ya 20 de sa voix
à retenir nos contextes ce que je vous
donne ce sont des règles générales y
aura toujours des exceptions mais il ya
plein d'endroits où les choses sont plus
ou moins pertinentes
si je reviens sur sur les choses a pas
faire je vous invite vraiment l'occasion
à les lire tout ça est notamment on y
reviendra sur des jolis graphiques sur
le les six morts c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut alléger un graphique je vous
montre le un type de graphique que
prennent les auteurs voyez ce graphique
il faut pas le faire pour plein plein de
raisons la police de caractère et pas
lisible vous avez du 3d oublier les
effets 3d ça montrera tout sauf votre
compétence au contraire puisque ont
perturbé l'oeil
vous avez trop d'éléments qui sont
représentés vous avez des étiquettes qui
sont du coup tournée donc c'est dur à
lire pour près alors pareil aujourd'hui
de fait jamais un graphique les hommes
en bleu les femmes en rose éviter en
rendant les clichés de genre et c'est
pas pertinent et c'est pas du tout
relevant tous les pourcentages ici sont
avec une décimale on n'a peut-être pas
besoin de tout ça le voici voilà ça
c'est le même graphique présenté
autrement par les auteurs c'est une
alternative voyons là quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus léger à l'oeil
beaucoup plus facile à lire et on a même
plus d'informations en fait en en ayant
mis beaucoup
vous avez ici toutes les étapes 1 de
réorganisation du graphique alors faire
un graphique aussi léger pour être
honnête à faire ça ça prend beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup de lignes de code
on aura alors plus on avril mais des
exemples de 2
deux graphiques avancées je ferai une
session dédiée la tue je crois que josé
j'ai déjà eu le temps de vous en
remettre un exemple sur un analyseur
[Musique]
d'en approfondir vous avez un chapitre
s'appelle exemple de graphiques avancés
y en a qu'un seul que j'ai eu le temps
de décrire pour le moment à sur un
graphique en barres mais voyez où on
passe de ce graphique l'un qui présente
en fait des connaissances avancées d une
enquête de connaissances et puis on
demande aux gens est ce qu'ils ont oui
non ne sais pas 1 à à à la toute fin ce
graphique l'a donc ce graphique là avec
des choix de couleurs qui sont plus
pertinents avec une organisation des
séquences avec un passage à
l'horizontale pour qu'on ait du coup
l'espace pour mettre des étiquettes
entière avec le texte exact des
questions parce que parfois plutôt que
de formuler des questions je vous
inviterai mettez le texte du
questionnaire c'est ce qui aura plus
précis on sera de quoi vous parlez
et voyez ce graphique la voici le code
correspondant
vous avez ici le code correspondant pour
ce graphique là je peux je vous ferai
une séance où je vous expliquerai étape
par étape comment on en arrive à ce
qu'au delà
mais voyez c'est beaucoup de temps ce
qui est du coût important à retenir
c'est que parfois passé déjà du temps
surtout si vous débutez de ggp lot 2 à
essayer de faire un bon graphique c'est
à dire les bons éléments qu'est-ce que
je dois mettre sur mon graphique comme
enjeu le structurer ce qui fait qu
est-ce que je m'en fasse aides quelles
sont les variables que je vais
représenter et et vous serez plus à
l'aise avec gégé pelote 2 de trouver
ensuite comment faire des graphiques
plus élégant plus propre où il ya -
peut-être - d'information alors là il ya
quand même un élément important qu'on va
faire c'est comment sauvegarder le
graphique
si je reviens ici
on a vu où on peut éventuellement
profiter de la fonction qu'on parle ou
porte pour faire un graphique au format
html car ça prend quelques secondes à
ceux calculés
mais avec ce qu'on appelle report on va
voir qu'on maîtrise qu qu'assez peu la
qualité graphique de ce qui va sortir on
pourra plus facilement avoir des
graphiques de taille différente
lorsqu'on va faire un r marc daoud qu'on
abordera plus tard on va voir néanmoins
en attendant comme moi ce que je peux
faire une sauvegarde propres de mon
graphique
je suis désolé pour le petit temps de
calcul voilà ça y est ça sort j'ai fait
un rapport au format html et j'ai ici
mon code avec tous mes graphiques qui
sorte d'accord par convoyer la
définition ici des graphiques et pas
forcément la plus belle qui soit 1 il ya
des appliques un peu par endroits on
pourrait éventuellement améliorer
j'avais abordé pour celles et ceux qui
étaient là la semaine dernière comment
est-ce qu'on pouvait un petit peu
personnaliser le report si vous faites
qu'on perd studio compass report
rené ya plein de choses je les connais
pas par coeur ce que je sais par contre
c'est comment les retrouver rapidement
sur internet
si je fais ça et reçus ou qu'on parle
porte j'arrive sur la page du site de r
studio qui va me parler de compas line
report est un moment donné vous avez
ou est ce que c'est ils ont changé la
documentation
voilà ici vous avez la possibilité
d'indiquer de manière un peu plus
globale la taille hauteur largeur des
figures on verra quand on fait des
rapports et remarques down que l'on va
pouvoir contrôler manière beaucoup plus
précise si j'avais le but
alors j'ai envie de vous dire vous
occupez pas de ça le temps que vous êtes
allé table de je fais mes analyses
exploratoire si je reviens sur le
rapport que j'ai fait là je clique sur
des ppte analysis viewers j'ai quelque
chose qui est largement suffisant pour
travailler dans l'immédiat
un temps que je suis à l'étape
exploratoire si je veux maintenant un
graphique un peu près propre
on va avoir 6 et un graphique gg pelote
comment on peut faire les choses un peu
mieux pour la sortie alors dans les
studios vous avez toujours la
possibilité là j'ai mon graphique quand
même de vous montrer une chose et si je
clique sur zoom vous pouvez afficher
votre graphique en grand d'accord ou
orange affiche en grand la taille
relative du texte à a été réduite
donc il ya un élément un peu particulier
c'est que la taille du texte vous
convions parfois grossir dégrossir notre
texte je peux toujours 10 bouton exporte
ici une copie tout clip aux douces et
vas-y match qui va me permettre
manuellement de d'exporter un graphique
mais ça c'est une option manuel et si je
remets un jour mon script j'ai devoir
tout refaire donc là ce qu'on va faire
je vais sauvegarder mon graphique donc
tout ça je vais mettre dans paix dans un
pays final je l'affiché ici dans mon
script mais surtout maintenant que j'ai
tout ça j'ai une fonction qui s'appelle
jauger c'est donc
j'essaye c'est pour sauvegarder un
graphique premièrement me demande le nom
du graphique d'accord donc c'est la
plaie graff reinhard rogoff et je vais
indiquer une extension si je fais point
png ça me fera un graphique au format
png le format png c'est un format points
comme le format jpeg mais s'en sont tout
à fait les mêmes pertes de données
si c'est pour mettre dans votre document
word powerpoint ou compagnie c'est un
bon format de base parce que vos
graphiques ne va jamais changer
on est fixé vous pouvez mettre pdf vous
ferez un graphique au format pdf soku
pdf c'est pas si simple que ça pour
ensuite leur importés dans un powerpoint
ou d'un document word vous avez svg
alors svg scalable vector graphics c'est
un graphique vectoriel dans un format
libre on peut modifier soit avec des
logiciels payants comme adobe
illustrator ou l'excellent logiciel
libre et gratuit in script
donc là on peut faire dur travail de
dessin sur un graphique derrière mais
c'est si on est déjà utilisateurs un peu
avancé donc retenu le formal plus
simples au quotidien ces formats png et
éventuellement parfois déformée au point
tiff tisf parce que certaines revues
vous demande un graphique au format tiff
un des gros intérêts de r c'est qu'on
fait on peut vraiment réexporter dans
plein de formats différents les
graphiques et je peux même faire faire
différent ggc du même graphique deux
éléments vous allez parler de klotz qui
permet de dire le graphique qu'on va
exporter
moi je veux dire je veux exporter paix
dans graff rina rogoff point png je peux
très bien faire un deuxième
gg c'est pour exporter au format pdf un
jeu peut exporter du coup on graphique
dans plein de formats différents
si je fais ça
donc si je fais ça d'accord ça va me
créer plusieurs fichiers l'âge un
fichier pdf si je louvre j'obtiens mon
graphique
alors je vais me mettre en plein écran
dans un format pdf d'accord
l'intérêt du format pdf c'est qu'on peut
zoomer de danse et ce sont des traits
des lignes donc c'est assez propre j'ai
une version qui est finie version png si
je clique sur png voici le graphique que
l'on obtient
ce qu'il est possible de être possible
de faire c'est d'améliorer la qualité du
graphique
alors je vais revenir sur mon png ici
les voir les différentes options qu'on a
dans gg c'est vous avez déjà des
paramètres reach inouïe qui permettent
d'indiquer la hauteur et la largeur du
graphique et units pour indiquer si vous
voulez parler en hygiène inches c'est à
dire en pousse américain en cm en mm
supposons que c'est pour la revue a
indiqué une taille particulière de
graphiques ou alors c'est pour ma thèse
dont je sais qu'ils sont roms sur une
thèse un document word en général on
peut faire un graphique qui va faire 16
cm de large
je vais faire oui illégal 16 pour aït
[Musique]
égale 10 pour avoir 10 cm de haut et je
vais préciser un peu plus espace mois là
et je vais préciser unit égal c'est m
donc là ça me permet d'indiquer que je
veux un graphique qui soit en cm qui va
faire 10 cm de large pour 16 cm de haut
voyons voir le graphique j'obtiens donc
ça c'est le png donc je tiens ce
graphique là si je regarde d'un peu plus
près voyez ça pixellise un peu hein
c'est pas forcément très fin un autre
élément qu à prendre en compte pour la
qualité d'un graphique c'est sa
résolution
la résolution d'un graphique s'est elle
exprimée en nombre de points par pouce
thot inches où on des pays plus le
nombre de points par pouce est élevé
meilleure est la qualité
quand vous faites un rapport en général
ça bouge sur les graphiques en 92 points
par pouce gg c'est par défaut vous
voulez 92 points par pouce et la
résolution usuels d'un écran 3 100
points par pouce est ce qu'on recommande
pour de l'impression d'ailleurs ggc vous
le fait par défaut
300 points par pouce mais si je veux
avoir une qualité encore un peu meilleur
je peux monter éventuellement à 600
points par pouce
en faisant ça alors attention mon
fichier il augmente
et quand je multiplie par deux le nombre
des pays la taille du fichier augmente x
4 mais on veut informatif un lui fait
neuf mégaoctet c'est vraiment très très
gourmand le format tiff d'ailleurs j'ai
du coup l'effacer ici c'est un peu trop
gourmand à ce stade
par contre si je regarde mon fichiers
png j'ai maintenant un fichier avec une
plus grande finesse ainsi je vous voyez
les serbes sont bien mieux dessiner donc
l'âge améliore la qualité de ma sortie
autres l'autre question qui peut se
poser c'est est-ce que je suis satisfait
de la taille du texte par rapport à la
taille du graphique est ce que là je
voudrais que le texte soit un peu plus
petit ou un peu plus grands alors une
possibilité déjà quand on applique un
thème ici on peut indiquer une taille de
base pour le texte qui va tout le reste
va s'en ressentir
mais on peut le faire directement le
monde gg c'est l'intérêt danger cfc
paramètres ce qu'est ce qu'il c'est une
sorte de facteurs d'échec qui fait
croire que c'est un peu plus gros un peu
plus petits si je fais ce qu elle égale
points 5 et que je fais le test
regardons le fichier obtenu
avec ce qu'elle points 5 hong kong a la
même taille de graphiques a même nombre
de points mais on fait croire que tout
est plus petit et voiliers du coup le
texte augmentant taille et il y en a
quelque chose qui est pas très lisible
si je fais ce qui est égal 2
simule un graphique plus grand et donc
du coup le texte apparaît plus petit
d'accord mais là le texte il est bien
plus petit jeu vous remonte ce qui se
passe avec un ce qu'elle a un
[Musique]
donc si je me dis ce qu'elle le texte un
peu trop grosse qu'elle de le texte un
peu trop petit et ben du coup on va je
peux mettre éventuellement un skill
points 1,5
[Musique]
jusqu'à trouver un résultat qui me
conviennent donc souvent ce que je vous
recommande de vous une fois que vous
aurez trouvé votre graffiti finale vous
jouez avec la fonction ce cri ans pour
la faire un petit peu plus grande un
petit peu plus petit jusqu'à se trouvait
finalement le bon équilibre
taille du texte par rapport à taille du
graphique si les étiquettes sont trop
petites votre graphique sera illisible à
l'impression si c'est trop gros du coup
on y lira pas grand chose dont on n'aura
pas assez d espace point graphique donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on va pouvoir
modifier étape par étape
[Musique]
je voulais c'est vous composez votre
tout dernière question puisqu'on va
s'arrêter là pour ce soir
voyez on aura passé quasiment deux
heures juste pour faire ce premier
exemple en termes de graphiques ce que
je vous propose dès lors ça va être de
modifier légèrement le programme à venir
parce qu'il ya encore beaucoup de choses
à dire sur sur sur ggp lot 2 et
notamment d'essayer de revenir sur les
différents graphiques unis by variés ce
qu'on n'a pas encore vu les graphiques
en bâton on n'a pas encore vu des
histogrammes on n'a pas encore vu tout
un tas d'autres graphique donc ce que je
vous propose c'est la semaine prochaine
de continuer sur ggp lot 2 et d'aborder
notamment tout ce qui va être graphique
unique variée qui sont les graphiques
qui vont servir le plus au quotidien qui
vont être des graphiques de base et puis
donc et puis seulement après et je
décalerait du coup les autres c'est les
autres sessions en conséquence voilà je
vérifie s'il reste des toutes dernières
questions qui n'auraient pas été répondu
[Musique]
pardon j'avais laissé passer cette
question de victoria david sur sur
l'orthographe britanniques et
américaines donc effective merci précisé
que color avec un us et l'orthographe
britannique et color avec un os et de
l'orthographe américaine en bon français
ont fait la queue fusion entre les deux
en permanence repris en tout cas que ggp
l'autre permet d'utiliser l'une et
l'autre et qu'on peut même mixer les
deux orthographes dans son code et une
question de savoir ce qu'on peut faire
des graphiques apparent secteur avec des
motifs de remplissage alors on verra du
coup la semaine prochaine comme on peut
faire des graphiques des graphique en
barres ou des graphiques on secteur on
peut facilement modifier la couleur il
existe des extensions à gg pelote 2 pour
pouvoir faire du remplissage avec des
motifs
c'est pas simple c'est possible mais
c'est un peu technique il faut passer
par des package qui sont pas encore très
bien stabilisé donc je vous dirai à
moins d'avoir un besoin très spécifique
sur un projet donné oublier le
remplissage avec des motifs en tout cas
pour le moment il n'ya pas encore
d'implémentation très très propre et
très simple donc du coup je m'arrête là
pour ce soir
bon courage à toutes et à tous je vous
invite à aller prendre le temps de
relire à tête reposée
du coup le chapitre donc sur un
analyseur d'aller lire le chapitre
d'introduction à gg pelote 2 qui est
d'en analyser la semaine prochaine on va
aborder en particulier du coup les
graphiques unis et bi varié avec gégé
pelote 2 donc revoir un différent type
de graphique nuages de points
histogramme graphique en barres
sachez aussi et voulait dans la partie
approfondir pour ceux qui sont
intéressés c'est que il ya plein
d'autres choses possibles il ya beaucoup
d'extensions sur ggp lot 2 donc on
n'aura pas le temps de tout exploré dans
l'est dans les prochains temps mais il
yad'autres géométriques qui sont
possibles il ya des graphiques plus
avancées il ya des graphiques complexes
qui sont proposés on abordera malgré
tout la semaine prochaine comment est-ce
qu'on peut combiner ensemble plusieurs
graphiques c'est à dire faire deux trois
graphiques et indépendant puis les
mettre ensuite sur un même graphique
sachez qu'il existe aussi impossible de
faire des graphiques interactifs vous
avez un graphique gbot de très basique
et on peut en faire un graphique
alteirac acteur actif si vous faites un
rapport web en fait et ça se fait en
ligne de code
j'ai des potes libre voulu passer un
graphique
et pareil sachez qu'il ya des choses qui
sont qui deviennent possibles à
attendait c'est dans cette dent
étrangers pelote de vous avez aussi dit
graphiques animés ou ses autres
extensions graphique voilà sachez qu'il
en fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités graphiques qui sont
possibles des diagrammes de sun qui sont
ce type de graphique là assez compliquée
mais qui parle de voir des flux elle est
extrêmement puissant quand il s'agit de
faire des graphiques vous avez diagramme
erquy d'extension pour faire des qui
elle dédiée à un diagramme et on peut
faire des choses assez intéressant ou
des drm de kant cirque live qui est
vraiment le package qui étaient dix à
tout ce qui va être graphique on cercle
retour jusque r est un package qui est
r en fait à beaucoup de package pour
faire des graphiques il ya plein de
choses possibles là on se contente
d'aborder la surface avec gégé pelote
plus vous utiliserez j'ai planté vous
découvrir qu'il ya plein de choses qui
sont possibles qui permettent d'aller
d'aller plus loin
on vous verrez un reviendra sur ggp lot
dont la plupart des prochaines séances
parce que on utilisera au quotidien et
puis au delà de ggp lot il ya plein
d'autres package qui propose aussi
d'autres options graphiques
une fois que ça paraît un petit peu
difficile qu'au démarrage mais
sincèrement une fois que vous avez bien
compris comment tout fonctionne vous
allez vous voudrez vous vous ne penserez
plus du tout logiciel excel très bonne
soirée à vous et du coup on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour la
continuation sur les graphiques gérer
pelote
merci à vous